people of the internet ori and the will
of
the wisps here we go
all right i'm just gonna go straight
into start game and we'll use the first
empty slot easy
for players who want to focus more on
story and less on challenging game play
normal the way or even was meant to be
played all right
okay yeah we're definitely going normal
we're definitely going normal
yeah our radiant for the longest time i
had
a a piece of artwork for this set as my
background on my computer
yeah i can definitely tell right away
it's not nearly as sharp as the
[Music]
as the pc version all right here we go
so
i mean it's like a painting come to life
i was waiting for it to play a scene but
no
this is me in control dude look at the
light through the tree right there
oh my goodness incredible swallows nest
okay
i just want to stop and take it all in
i just want to take in the gorgeous
backgrounds oh hey i remember this dude
what's up
okay all right so we we've got
let's see what all do we have at our
disposal right now because part of the
first game a lot of it was like you
learn abilities as you go
so i have kind of a double jump but only
if i'm running
up the side of a wall like that like you
can kind of get a little extra boost
there
we shall always remember the day
david what the day that what
i'm on the edge of my seat what happened
okay there we go
when new life came to nibble
oh so
sweet yes we do
we named her coo all right
you talking about from this game our
radiant
a background
oh look at the little owl
no they disappeared okay they're they're
growing up
they're growing up together i think it's
the what they're going for right now
oh just a random one
[Music]
it's been so long since i played the
first one i barely remember anything
but i do remember that that first
creature that we saw
okay what now
oh he's waking up
oh my goodness dude this game is just so
incredibly gorgeous
once again this is the switch version
guys and it still looks
this great
all right i guess we go this way then
there they are oh is he gonna try to fly
you could do a little one come on come
on
there you go not bad that was your first
try not bad at all
the owl from there no no that's
definitely not hedwig
[Music]
nope you don't want that what come on
it's good
cory's like hold up you wanna you wanna
go up here and get something else
we can help you with that oh under the
log okay
[Music]
oh now we got the winter scene
you know what i should also put that
this is like a first time play through
and a blind playthrough
[Music]
heard it too
oh here we go a disturbance
hey that still wasn't too bad
oh there goes my dog you guys probably
can't see her now because the
webcam is too small yep she's making her
bed back there
making her bed back in the corner
oh no we gotta go find him
okay we can do this you can do this
the thing with the long legs really
freaks you out not gonna lie
yeah there's a moment in the first game
i'm pretty sure
you guys can correct me if i'm wrong but
i'm pretty sure there's a moment in the
first game where you think that that's
like the bad
what's guy on here little fireflies
oh don't be sad
[Music]
don't be sad we're here for you
oh they're just like showing off man
within the first 10 minutes of the game
the artists are showing off showing all
these incredible scenes
now we got the night scene we've already
had a winter scene
this looks fantastic
the answer lay in the past
okay all right so we go this way
or he's so nimble and quick
there we go her mother's final gift
okay can i go in now
let's see are we gonna have to bounce
off this way there we go
what is this treasure
do we have treasure
kuros feather you've gained a new
ability while airborne holds zr to glide
freely
or ride wind currents nice already
getting a new ability that fast
love it love it
there we go
it's like link breath of the wild
i'm gonna try to cheer him up with that
there you go buddy look we have a
surprise
ori such a good sibling such a good
now they're basically siblings right
they're being raised together
i mean that it doesn't the long-legged
creature does look pretty uh
creepy right there oh geez
[Music]
will this work will this work
ah
nice
oh my goodness okay this is a new
mechanic right away
this is a new mechanic
oh my goodness this is great together on
new wings
the sky was within reach oh wow
dude
because i'm pretty sure the mother the
big owl
well i don't know spoiler alert for the
first game
i mean if you're watching this one
hopefully you don't care about spoilers
for the first game
right but i'm pretty sure the
the mother owl dies at the end of the
first game
or at some point in the first game like
i said it's been a while since i played
it but
all of you guys correct me if i'm wrong
okay so they're like in the in the sky
we can see what looks like an older
i'm not really sure what i'm supposed to
be doing right here
i don't think i can get up there
maybe go back this way
anything over here nope okay
have i gotten into pokemon cards yet i
have not no
hey didn't you love those cards i
tweeted at you though i mean that's
that's what everybody's after right
those are the pokemon cards i laughed so
hard when i found those i was like what
is this
what is this version of pokemon
card that i have here
there you go nice
[Music]
no my mom was looking too we couldn't
find any of my old pokemon cards
and be fair i never had a big big
collection anyway
[Music]
but the way the way things are going
right now with pokemon cards
i mean i couldn't just walk into the
store and buy them could i i would have
to like
camp out waiting for their
new load to arrive
maybe throw some hands let's get pokemon
cards
oh goodness oh yeah you guys will enjoy
this i put up a poll
on youtube asking do you own any pokemon
cards
and 627 votes
and right now it's 51 yes 49 no
so basically you know 312
315 own pokemon cards
that have voted in the poll so far
did you vote on that one nice
all right so i'm wondering like where
are they going here are they trying to
is the owl wanting to find out more
about his past
or what because it seems like
it seems like he's longing for his kind
you know
he's all sad or he brings him the wing
oh we got a storm guys we got a storm
this is not looking good on that wing
no we just got that power up
we just got the power up
oh this is making me mad already no
you're already separating the two of
them
no
separated by the storm there we go our
story began
okay so the two basically siblings close
friends i guess we could call them
but they have been separated so it seems
like that is our inciting event here to
start
ori and the wheel of the wisps
you have like three million youtube
accounts
oh i i i think i responded because i
know somebody commented on that about it
being 50 50 or something was that you
no not this soon into the game
all right now we find ourselves in
inkwater marsh
all right so it's showing me down there
x y and a i'm not really sure
those are clearly going to be some power
ups or something that we use
do i have do i have the feather for
myself no i don't
i don't have i don't have the feather
for myself
well that was kind of sneaky i thought
that was a barrier right there
never mind
ouch okay that hurt me i thought not
mario style okay we
we can't hop on them
there we go that gave us some life right
there life orb yeah
collect these to restore oris life under
dustin
m okay i'll i'll check for that
[Music]
i will check for that oh no
hold b to jump higher
okay that's simple what oh no
oh no oh no that water's hurting us okay
we cannot go in the water
good to know good to know guys if you're
watching this later on
youtube know that you can also check out
these live
some things i post on youtube are
recorded only for youtube
oh no i just did it again and i died
first death there we go
yeah some of the things i record just
for youtube and some things i actually
stream live over on my twitch channel so
twitch.tv retro rack and tour if you
guys are interested
in the stream and you can uh hang out
interact with me in the chat okay
we already found the life orb so it
didn't save that apparently
oh yeah we were ready that time jumped
over it
okay i don't think we're gonna be able
to get up above
oh my goodness get out of there get out
of three hits and i'm dead
yikes does it control pretty well yeah
it does don't let my
do not let my failures right now fool
you our radiant gaming
it absolutely does control very well
this is just me trying to
remind myself about the controls and to
also see if i can get to any areas that
honestly the game probably doesn't want
me getting to yet
but i just want to try it anyway
oh can i just keep doing that oh yes you
can
oh goodness no stop worry
okay wow can i not get any momentum
going with this
oh we just made it
okay luma pulls to the left inkwater
marsh to the right don't ask me
why i just initially started to the left
i feel like in so many games especially
the older like side scrolling games it
was always left to right
but with this one wait it said something
hold zr to grab and move
objects there we go okay
but with this one it's more of a
metroidvania style so you can go either
way
okay you found a lifestyle fragment
collect one more to increase your
maximum life okay so you need two i got
half of one here
and that will increase my overall health
and actually yeah it looks like the
camera's in a pretty good spot right
here bottom left so i don't think i need
to change anything
unless oh direct hit
yeah i don't think we can yeah we're
dead we're dead again guys
i don't think we could do anything that
way yet so okay so it auto saved after i
grabbed this
power up right here so i'm gonna head go
ahead and go back
and head to the right from the beginning
oh my goodness can you not get up here
ori
there we go all right so we're going to
go back to inkwater marsh
if i don't die in the process
oh we barely made that
and at some point i need to get an
attack button
because right now i don't think i can
attack all right is there any way for me
to get down there
i don't believe so so that's an item
we'll get later
all right so let's go to the right
instead
now it didn't hurt going that way the
good news is that we got that little
half
health piece so we just need one more
okay there we go what is this thing
small spirit like container
spirit light can be traded to friendly
creatures for various items and upgrades
all right good deal good deal
good to know
no that is not good right there come on
dude just we're just having rotten luck
at the beginning of this game
so much is not going your way worry
all right i don't know if i can land in
that water or not
okay wait hold and press b to fall
through
platforms
[Music]
wait what go ahead and grab this
oh oh i thought i was trying to do like
a ground pound okay i just hold down and
then press
b there we go simple just do exactly
what it said
don't make it harder than it is retro i
have a tendency to do that guys
i apologize yeah let's drop down here
see if there's some secret hiding here
oh those do not look like friendly
creatures
[Music]
press y to grab a torch
can i use this to attack oh you can
nice i don't know if that's the ultimate
point of this but oh goodness back
oh man it takes three hits to take those
guys out
spirit light orb yeah you already told
me that
you already told me that that was kind
of everyone looked a little different
though
smaller okay
anything over here okay so i can attack
really quick i don't need to do it
in little short separate hits oh can i
burn this down
there we go all right
what's going on over here oh what is
that thing
about to find out are you friendly
tell me you're friendly come on yes okay
squawk what are you now not a moki
moki or mokai clearly i think it's weird
it was why to talk and it's also
why to attack i don't know if that's the
wisest choice on their part but okay
not even from nowhere are you i've
visited most lands near and far and not
seen your kind come
from across the water maybe
but whatever you are i'm talk a wanderer
in these parts
the better parts at least i'm taking
shelter from that storm myself but if
you're thinking of going further you'll
have to get through the spirit gate over
there
you'll need two keystones i happen to
have one in my bag and there's another
in the cave
to the west okay so we're going the
right direction we need to go that way
been playing through age of calamity i i
have that one on my radar too
i've been thinking about picking that up
acquiring it as a job for someone more
nimble than myself what do you say
oh we got you press what is that minus
request details okay all right inkwater
marsh we've explored
six percent of it all right let's look
at details here
oh if you hold y it'll show you the
details
let's zoom in i can hardly see anything
okay energy cell fragment
it labels that on the map and our buddy
talk
is right here so we want to go all the
way
to find the keystone retrieve the
missing keystone from the cave beyond
talk and he'll give you his okay so i
gotta go find that one first
all right let's do it
and we've got full health right now
that's the little green
circles at the bottom
all right i can drop down right there
but
well that dude is that dude is on fire
found an energy orb collect these to
restore ori's energy
yeah let's branching paths man
i always i have to go and explore i just
have to see what's in the other
branching path okay this might be the
secret right here yeah there we go
all right so we got 162 of those things
i wonder if i get to keep this torch or
if i can lose it somehow
oh no i did not mean to do that
dude gotta get a little bit closer
oh i want all these things no
that was risky that was very risky but i
went for it
paid off alright i do think i may have
missed some things up here though
no oh goodness
no that's okay
because i think the save point oh it put
me at the bottom
i was thinking it would put me at the
top
no i don't think i can make this
oh we made it dude oh but there's
another one right there yeah we're not
gonna be able to make it back up
must have to go another way
oh goodness what's going on oh
is that like a dark version of ori what
is happening
oh goodness no
and just like that just like that he
took us out
yeah yeah we know we know it's almost
like he
phased through me
oh wait maybe we need to do this
there we go there we go we got him that
time
our health is dangerously low though
hopefully there's yeah there's a little
health
board right over there i don't know what
the point of that area was maybe it was
just
oh i do see another health container up
here
oh but i can't i don't think i can get
back up there
it's all right hopefully we'll be okay
oh the backstory is in age of calamity
no we just lost our torch
all right well that answers my question
about can you lose your torch
the answer is yes i think it was clearly
intentional though because there's no
way to get through this without
without losing your torch
[Music]
whoa this is weird all right see here we
go branching paths again
i want to explore this way
i don't have anything to combat that guy
and i don't even
think i can reach that point up there
because there's none of the blue moss
so i just yeah i think i have to go this
way
all right so we're gonna have to okay
this water is cool all right
[Music]
okay so then we can hop here
jump over and get this okay that's one
of them right there the keystone
keystones are used to open spirit gates
different spirit gates may require
a different number of keystones all
right
so this one requires two i believe now
we need to go back to talk
but we haven't even fully explored this
area over here there's something right
there what is that
something purple and then looks like you
can go even further to the left there
i don't know see that's the thing about
these types of games though i have no
idea if i
if i have all the tools i need
to adequately explore that area yet okay
so here's where i went down
all right so now we know where that
leads yeah so now i'm heading back
because i don't think i can get to any
of those other areas right now
especially now that i don't even have
the torch i don't have any
movement upgrades at all all i've got is
like the double jump right now well it's
not even really a double jump you can
just
kind of climb up walls all right here's
our buddy talk
oh you're done you're back and is that a
keystone
you got it dude one more for your
trouble i'm ever a bird of my word
hmm now i can continue my wanderings
through
new ones i don't think that's how you
say it nevin maybe
nywin i'm going to say nywin through
nywon's lost wonders
before we lose anymore and you can carry
on with
whatever it is you're doing good luck
all right there we go that's two of them
[Music]
now let's take a look at our map so now
we can open a
s a spirit gate or something like that
okay that's an energy cell fragment we
need to try and get that
a gorlick or
all right i'm glad it left it leaves it
labeled on the map so we know
just by the fact that that's there we
know we need to do some exploring over
in that area at some point
oh goodness
i botched it and botched it again
okay right there's where we need to get
dude i need to get that torch again
okay the torch was up here right
oh goodness i didn't even see that guy i
didn't even
see that guy
i love how you just like instantly
respawn in this game oh
that doesn't look good they just they
know you're gonna be dying a lot so
they're just like here here you go
what is this over here oh this is where
we got the fire
so you're telling me i can't get it back
oh
no there's got to be another one close
by right
please i want to see if i can open that
area down there
alright so here's where i put in the
keystone
that opens that up all right
oh and there's something up there too
see that in the top
kind of middle of the screen
i think i can swim here yeah
he does have a little bar though
it's very nimble in the water too
actually
[Music]
all right we don't really need any
health right now so i'm not gonna worry
about that
dude already i thought i would have a
little while to worry about this thing
oh goodness this is not good i'm dead
i'm dead what maybe
i have no idea am i supposed to go to
the left
no
apparently not
what dude what is happening
oh i can jump over that
no no no no no
give me the flames yes get him ori
bash him in the face and he ate me
and he ate me he took
one bite and ate me
[Music]
dude you have to be quick right
come there come on come on get the torch
get the torch
bash him in the face dude now get out of
the way
is that his health bar what the heck is
this dark souls man
no
okay i'm being too greedy classic dark
souls right here guys
you can never be too greedy let's go in
for two hits okay never mind not even
two hits
go ahead go ahead all right here we come
one
two back out back out all right all
right
one two okay we did three and we got
punished for it man
no where am i supposed to go
where am i supposed to go
you got this never mind
okay i think there's no way to avoid
getting hit right there because that's
like what launches you forward
like i don't know how to avoid that
right there
oh if you stay under him i was thinking
maybe i could get under him and
completely dodge those hits
but that's like insta kill right there
insta kill when you go under him
so the dark souls classic move of
getting behind your enemy doesn't seem
like it's gonna work in this guy
like how do i avoid this when he i see
right now i could do this all day
but then eventually he's gonna start
pressing forward even more
dude it's almost impossible to get like
two hits
okay there we go there we go there we go
i felt like any time i went for two it
would go for three
and then whenever i went for three he
almost always got me
yeah close call indeed you're telling me
you're telling me and clearly he wasn't
gone we're gonna see him throughout the
game
no doubt because his health bar was
not even halfway down and of course we
have to go back this way i can't go this
way come on i want to go away from that
dude
i do not want to go any closer to that
thing
oh i don't want to go down here i want
to go
i don't want to go all right where's a
merchant i want to be able to buy some
stuff here
okay housed in i don't think we can get
through there anyway so i'm not even
gonna worry about it over there on the
right
yeah it looks like you're gonna need
something to either burn that down or
knock it down
yeah same same thing as right here
dude what is that moving over there on
the left
you see that green what
all these bones this area is
not very pleasant
okay we got more bones here no i don't
want to go where that dude is man let's
look at the map
not gonna help me don't know which way
to go all right i'm gonna choose left
again
okay we've got another uh keystone right
here and we do not have any to turn in
and we can yeah there's no way we're
making that so we go to the right
to the right we go
okay i think those things might actually
be friendly because they're not
attacking me
that's always a good sign oh here we go
branching paths again
yeah i don't think we can do anything
with this right now
i don't think we can do anything with
that
cutscene
oh that looks powerful
that looks like something useful right
there i'm just saying
hey nice talking to you our radiant
always nice chatting with you hope you
have a good night thanks for stopping by
[Music]
power up power up power up
kind of power up did we get
as an ancient light awakened
of course we'd have a lot of texts right
after i tried to eat a chocolate covered
almond
naru and gumo sought through the night
yeah because they're looking for us now
they're concerned
we must get back to you
all right there's ori what did we get
out of this what did we get
oh man that is gorgeous right there
i'll just take a screenshot of that
because that was beautiful you're not
like the others the shrieker the howler
in you shines an ancient light
the tree remembered it knowed it glowed
it has shared its memory with you
spirit edge you've gained a new ability
hold zl to assign it to y
x or a and unleash combo attacks
all right i think this is our basic
attack now use the light we want to see
so i'm definitely going to put that on y
attack at close range with a blade of
light yeah we want that on y
all right there we go there we go
now we can do some damage don't have to
worry about finding a torch
to put up a fight
all right nicely done ori nicely done
i don't know where my little buddies
went they said they wanted to see
don't run away
all right collect that
dude this game is just so fluid it just
feels just the movement feels so good
okay those things take a little bit more
to knock them down
looks like we got something special over
here a magnet you've gained a new spirit
shard orbs float to ori from further
away hey that's pretty cool
press minus to equip what is this i
remember anything like this in the first
game
but again it's been a while inventory
dude this inventory is huge
so we're gonna be able to get a lot of
these shards but looks like you can only
have three equipped at a time
and so that what this one will do orbs
float to ori from a half screen away
next level orbs float to ori from a
great distance away that'll be super
useful to have
once we get that
[Music]
all right let's take out this guy right
here
all right we're already at max health so
i don't know that there's a point to
grab that
what's going on over here oh there they
are they didn't completely abandon us
okay good
the light listens to you you must be a
spirit after all
we mokai thought all the spirits had
gone from niawin
gone away you seek someone we know a
finder the great one great and
mossy go to the guardian of the marsh
woe lock will help you find your way quo
lock
cloak sounds pretty flippin cool
guardian of the marsh all right let's go
let's do it track quest i think it's
already being tracked
press minus c details
[Music]
oh breakable floor spirit gate i love
how it labels these things
ancestral tree
i kind of want to go back for this
energy cell fragment
i bet i can knock it down now with my
with my new ability i just viewed the
map what are you talking about
oh we can go down here now too though i
think that's why they wanted me to look
right there
i think that is why they wanted me to
check that
that's got some range on it let's go
[Music]
yikes man
all right we got a little bit of help
after we took him out
i don't really know if i'm supposed to
be going this way right now but i just
that's the great thing about this game
man you just like there's so many little
areas you can go off and explore
all right let's take this guy out
and see this this branches again we
could go left or right right here
it's gonna help me lower this or
something
[Music]
okay i know we can move it but what's
the point of moving it
just to help me reach that maybe
oh it's the big guy again please don't
tell me it's the wolf again
what is this thing dude
i'm terrible dodging we need a dodge
move is there not a dodge move
all right i almost had him but
oh yeah we got you now
dude this thing has way more range than
you first think way more range than you
think at first
i like it it's awesome
like see look at this now we were
supposed to go up at first i wanted to
see like what's under here if i could
break this then i wanted to see what's
over here
then i wanted to see what this does and
then we just get sidetracked man the
game's like hey pull up your map
oh yeah i can go this way and now here
we are
exploring this is not even the direction
we're supposed to go we're supposed to
be going
i think we're supposed to be going
way up there yeah so
oops didn't mean to zoom out that far
yeah way over there is where we're
supposed to be going
i mean who knows maybe this will loop
back around somehow but
more of those guys
i really need a dodge move
otherwise i'm just going to get wrecked
i mean you guys have already seen it
i've been wrecked plenty of times
already no come on or you can do this
you can do this oh no
wait i think i have an idea
let's see if i can kind of do this right
here
and then jump over there we go
hmm
oh we messed up okay
i think we're gonna need we need uh some
sort of power up
oh my gosh we don't need a power up to
to clear this because i know i just did
it
there we go yeah that right there
yeah i don't think we can make that jump
all right well now we know
we came this way so we couldn't go there
but we could try and keep going to the
left here
see if that leads us anywhere
oh yes press y to absorb the light
[Music]
double jump oh my goodness yes
dude yes double jump let's go
press b to jump then be again to go even
higher yeah that's going to be super
useful
i'm glad we went that way now
i'm really glad we went that way
[Music]
wait what wait what
i didn't let me double jump right there
wait why is it not letting me it let me
right there
i i think i'm i think i'm coming off the
wall before i realize it
oh yeah right there there we go
sticky you've gained a new spirit shard
ori sticks to walls
oh my goodness another spirit shard
already
yeah that's gonna be pretty helpful too
look at that
can i get up there
that's crazy
[Music]
hold on hold on is there a secret down
here
no okay i keep forgetting i've got
double jump now i was like there's no
way i can make that jump
oh can i not make that jump yet
totally looks like there's something up
here doesn't it
like i'm pretty sure you could get on
that limb right there
but that might be the way i just came
from i'm terrible with directions guys
i'm so bad
[Music]
oh no that is the way i came but this
way
now that we've got the double jump
it should be no problem for us to do
this right here
so satisfying man so satisfying
okay and i think if i'm right i think
this just loops back
where we just came from
yeah it does okay no need in worrying
about anything over here then
yep just take us back there all right
perfect now
we can go back up here and i want to see
i want to see what this does right here
i want to see what the energy cell
fragment gives us
oh and he can stick those too
wait what was it about oh it was telling
me how i could move that right right
right
is there any way to drop through this
because i feel like there's more if i
can go down below here
monkey birds dude what is up man
what is up you've been gone a long time
yeah i took
took a couple months break and we've
done a few streams here and there but
nothing
nothing regular yeah it's been kind of
off and on
i don't even i wouldn't even say off and
on we we did like
two or three streams couple weeks ago
there was a week where i had the whole
week off and i just did like several
streams during the day
but it wasn't like a regular thing it
was just hey guys i'm off this week
let's do some streams
yeah man we've been doing a lot of work
over on the youtube the youtube is
really
really taking off that's where i've been
doing a lot of my
all my all my time and effort lately
when i'm not at my real job or with
family has been going into that but
i'm hoping to add streams back as a
regular
weekly occurrence now and right now it's
looking like
honestly like i'm leaning towards like
tuesday thursday or maybe tuesday
wednesday
dang that dude took me out but i haven't
really decided yet
but it's definitely they're definitely
coming back oh goodness
double jump indeed okay but wait isn't
this just yeah this is where i was it
put me all the way back over here
but how about you monkey birds what you
been into what games you've been playing
lately
all right let's go all the way over
okay we need oh that's breakable too
right there
breakable floor let's see can i do i
have what i need to break this
right now i do not
yeah even with a double jump and then
down he doesn't break it
so
dude this attack is awesome i can't
believe this is just like the most basic
attack
mario 35 that's aw isn't that going is
it going away
i can't believe some of the stuff's
nintendo nintendo is doing with this
mario 35th anniversary thing man
i picked up the
the um oh what's it called super mario
3d
all-stars and that you know like once
you have it
you own it it's not going anywhere but
they are they're like gonna stop selling
the game at the end of this month
both digitally and at retail like
nintendo
come on this makes no sense
i hate like that forced scarcity but
i've seen with mario 35 like
is that the same deal like you just
can't buy it or is like the game itself
actually going away we can destroy those
now that we've got that i didn't know
that
you never seen this game oh dude it's
it's so gorgeous
sequel to ori in the blind forest
which i streamed a few years ago
oh my goodness and i got this one for
christmas for the switch and i was like
you know what i should stream that
it just has an absolutely incredible art
style the art style is
gorgeous in this game okay that's the
spirit gate we can't do anything with
that
dude we're not going to be able to make
it back up to that that spot yet
here's where i want to get to to check
some things out but yeah we
we do not have the ability to get up
there right now
or do we or do we
it's gonna be tough but i think
all right we got in there for that one
that's one of the slabs that we needed
but that's still not gonna help us get
up to over here
oh it's mario 35 is a free game so get
they're removing it for everyone that
just makes no sense to me nintendo
and from what i've heard people have
really been enjoying that
that mario 35
okay so i guess we're just gonna have to
go this way and then
work our way over actually hold on you
know what i'm gonna explore i'm gonna
make sure i checked out everything over
here first
and we clearly did not yeah we didn't
come this way at all
[Music]
i just can't get over the art style in
this game man the artists
for this game are so ridiculously
talented
like in a weird way it reminds me of the
first time i saw metroid prime
and i know it's like i guess the games
are somewhat
similar because metroidvania style
sort of what ori is but metroid prime
first person
but that was a game on the gamecube
which was certainly not the most
powerful
system at the time i mean it was more
than capable
but when metroid prime came out it was
it was the best looking game
on console
and so much of that was because of the
incredibly talented artists
at retro dude that thing just destroyed
i really do need like a dodge i need a
dodge move
you guys are like actually retro no you
just need to stop being greedy
and get away just take your hit
and then get away these guys right there
we can usually be greedy with them
though
all right nice okay here here he comes
he's up here
see like i should have just backed away
all right there's my hit
yikes
oh he got me again dude
[Music]
no more no more chat
chest like i don't believe you
i don't believe you no we got this dude
we got this
see that extra hit man oh good he fell
he fell and then he just ran into those
spikes and died
wow okay
no no no no don't die to this guy
we almost did after we took out the
difficult guy
all right we do need some help though
we do need some health though
i don't want to run into another there
we go
all right that only takes us up to two
full orbs though
so is that the whole point of that
little area right there that's it
i guess so yeah
double check make sure there wasn't a
hidden spot
okay nothing over there
this tree like feels that's where i know
that's where i got the power up but
you could just still feel the power
emanating from that tree
yeah this is what i want to check
nothing over here okay so that's a hard
hard wall right there i guess we're
gonna have to go down this way
right in there and that right there is
breakable breakable floor
but i don't think we have the ability
yet to break it
yeah so this whole area was just too
so there's nothing i can get over here
nowhere i can go
all right all right fair enough just
making sure
[Music]
yeah so we're gonna have to go
i need to drop down at my next
opportunity
right here
you almost got me
all right so let's drop down from here
there we go
the light from the wells runs all
through niwin it joins it heals
[Music]
i can definitely use some heels right
now press y to activate the spirit well
and restore
life and energy and it saves the game
excellent
i actually didn't know if there was an
auto save i know there's a checkpoint
system but
let's see backup saves
okay it's been saving the whole time
good good good
good good good just making sure
so you can use that unlimited
good to know all right so that's what's
over there so we need to keep heading
down
yeah this is the breakable one right
here but
and there is another slab right there
directly below and there's a little
switch up here
or a lever i need to pull that
there we go dude that's what lowers that
we were wondering remember we were over
there like how do i get this
i thought the boulder was gonna help
lower it but it did not
so now we need to just head back up
now we can drop down here
so fight this guy right here
oh i don't know about this we're gonna
need our little rock over here
come on move it move it or e there you
go
okay now what though all right so it
just blocks it so we're just going to be
able to
you guys see that i very nearly jumped
completely over that
all right so now we've got both slabs
and we can go and open
this right here all right so let's go
back up
i think we'll need to start over here on
this side
anything special in here nope
can i make that jump right there let's
see with the double jump yes we can
not even close we can easily clear that
all right so we need to go up here
gotcha
oh back to this spot again
no sorry we got some health right there
anyway waiting for us
come on alright get get
get up there
yep not even gonna bother with you not
even gonna bother going straight to the
insert the keystones here all right
we've got some poisonous water i can see
right off the jump that water does not
look like water that we can
safely traverse through
no i almost went into the water anyway
all right double jump right there
just barely man just barely
come on fall down fall down
there we go
oh can i make that you guys see that
right top right i
clearly they're trying to force me into
the middle spot right there by the way
the camera is shifting
but you guys know me i'm always curious
about the
yeah i don't think we can make that yet
all right but where does this go if i
keep going down
okay that's the area we've already been
to don't even bother
i don't like the looks of this
okay wasn't too bad it wasn't as bad as
i thought
yeah lifestyle so that's our second one
we completed it
and now our maximum life has been
increased adds it makes it four
orbs that's perfect that's perfect
clearly we're going to need as many of
those as we can find
judging by the way the first hour or so
of the game has went for us so far
okay i guess we wanna
this is just this is areas we've already
explored
but it's getting us all the way back up
top here
yeah that's the spirit well over there
i'm i'm guessing we're gonna have to go
in this
direction but i want to check in with
this ancestral tree and then i want to
go and get that
energy cell fragment actually we already
know exactly what's going to be at the
tree
we know exactly what the tree has
there you go there you go
nope not even bothering
dude we're getting a ton of these spirit
shards right off the bat here that's
great
deal and take more damage
yes please dude all three of these
shards right now are incredibly useful
in the they're the first three we got
it's going to be a difficult choice
having to decide what to
remove later on i mean i guess the
magnet
that one's useful but it's not really
necessary
sticky and climb on walls like that
one's super helpful and so is this this
one's gonna be huge
the next level you if you increase it
then you'll deal damage
and reduce damage by 25 right now it's
15 percent come here you
no can we not make that of course we can
make that
okay so i want to yeah i want to keep
going
past the tree
i thought this was the tree i'd already
been to but i guess not
regenerate you've gained a new ability
hold zl sign it to yx or a
and spend energy to recover life
what what
i think i'm gonna put that on x
no wait what spirit edge
oh okay you rotate the left analog stick
so yeah that's i've got spirit edge on y
that's the attack move
and then this channel energy to heal
it's amazing so i'm at full health right
now but i'm
that's that's going to be super useful
and i guess the energy is just the uh is
there anywhere for me to see it see how
much i have right now
i think it's the gold yeah so i've got
532 energy right now
all right so i really want to go and i
want to check and see if i can get
this right here this is what i'm going
for this energy cell fragment
yes oh no are you serious i can't
destroy that
i can't believe it won't let me destroy
that
i know i've already been this way
dude that guy does a lot of damage but
here's what here's what i want to see
like should i even bother going that far
to get this thing it's it's a garlic ore
i bet i can get it now though because i
do have double jump i'm going for it
i'm a completionist guys what can i say
what can i say
i say that and yet i probably won't find
everything in this game
i still probably won't find everything i
certainly didn't in the first ory
yes there you go okay now all this stuff
i think this is
this is where i came out the first time
yeah it is
but if i follow this all the way
[Music]
okay not there need to drop a little bit
there it is right there all right so
let's go down
use this right here
no okay dude there's got we there's
gotta be a way to get over there
okay got right there no problem
nice okay what does this thing give me i
have no idea we may have wasted our time
completely
garlic or you found some ore a clever
craftsman could use this to repair
structures
hmm what kind of structures what kind of
structures are we talking here
i'm trying to think if there's anything
i've seen so far that could need to be
repaired
see now we can keep going to the left
here even though the game's like no
you're supposed to be going this way
okay this i probably should i probably
should listen to the game now
and go this way
yeah it'll just be faster to go this way
all right so we basically just need to
go all the way to the right now
i'm guessing
i can't believe it won't destroy that
i've got to get the fire back but i lost
it
no i thought i could attack you
[Music]
all right so to make sure i don't make a
wrong turn here
[Music]
is there anything up there i'm already
right here i might as well check
yikes i didn't think he would come up
here again
i saw you up there but i didn't think
you'd come back
[Music]
yes he like just getting that double
jump has opened up a lot of areas that
we didn't have
even even this early lupo
lupo say what
greetings traveler i am lupo map maker
extraordinaire
quite the storm that passed through made
my maps a little soggy so i'll give you
half off agreed sounds good dude
after all rumor has it you're looking
for a friend and what's better for
finding things than a map
this is true
absolutely my friend he's not much
obliged much obliged
all right now let's check out our map is
it going to show me all the areas
i'll be even better if it has everything
labeled
yes it does show you the secrets too
okay so does it wait does it show me
it shows me this whole area right here
it doesn't show me anything
near this which is where we need to be
going talk to the guardian of the marsh
okay so we've got a shrine up here we've
got a shrine down here as well behind
the breakable floor
ancestral tree over here as well
oh if we could if we would have kept
going that way
that's what we would have hit over there
probably should have done that but oh
well
so right now we're about to go into this
big area up here we got another
ancestral tree coming up as well as a
shrine
can i go through right there no i can't
so i'm gonna have to go back to the left
and then
up
and i wonder where that leads right
there
let's see if he has anything else for
sale might as well
there's danger in a name friend
say for instance the name of this place
inkwater marsh
i tried using some of that water to draw
my maps and uh well
oh wait i dropped i stopped doing the
voice waste of good paper that
[Music]
interesting so we need to pay close
attention to the names of each
each little world that we go into
because we were talking about how you
putting uh the purple
water you can't go into it
i mean you can't but you're going to be
injured when you do
dude i really want to get up there
[Music]
oh come on can i not grab onto this
darn it i guess later i guess later guys
all right so we can take those out into
two sets
if we get all the hits in
all right before i do this
yeah let's see if we can go up here
oh man i just love the exploration okay
this one ends in a dead end though
so i actually think this is the way we
should go first
over here oh no i messed up
i messed up
i saw it too late guys i was already in
midair
yeah resilience you've gained a new
spirit shard reduced damage taken
dude the spirit shards are just dropping
like crazy
okay wait reduce take 10
less damage and i've already got the
i've already got
this one that does increase damage
wait a second okay i did not read that
correctly earlier
it increases damage dealt and your
damage taken i thought it reduced your
damage taken an
increased damage dealt oh okay that's a
little bit
that's a little bit more uh iffy then
for me i think i would rather have
man we've got a tough choice here
already do you go with the defense
the defensive perk of being able to just
take 10 less damage
oh man because yeah then if you do that
one so if you equip them both
let's let's do a little math here that
would give me
take ten percent less damage while this
one would increase my damn
so i'd overall overall
i would be taking five percent more
damage if i had both of them on
and i would be dealing 15 more
oh this is tough man this is tough
i think for now i'm gonna drop that one
and i'm gonna do take ten percent less
damage
that's what i'm gonna go with for now
and the sticky is just too useful
i could drop magnet but that one's
probably the least useful right now it's
just nice to have
all right we'll try that for now i mean
clearly i think we're gonna have to like
cleanse this area or something
first before we can yeah there's no
there's no way we can swim through that
water
we would not survive that
i promise i didn't mean to do that we
wouldn't survive if i tried it
we definitely could not survive that
all right so let's go back up now and i
guess we gotta
decide which way we want to go here does
that end in a dead end
oh man i definitely want to go to the
right like there's more stuff over here
to explore for sure
but i definitely want to try to try to
get to this shrine and try to get to
this ancestral tree here
so that's what we're gonna do
oh another little person another little
person to meet along the way
got to see the view splendid isn't it
the wellspring and all her magnificence
a whole generation of mochai have come
and gone since the old mills
wheels last turned and they say
dude come on you didn't even let me
finish what
is that an owl
what shriek doing all the way out here
something must have stirred her from her
roost some threat perhaps
not you surely you look harmless we
should fix that
luckily for you i just happen to be a
weapon master
yo weapon master let's go
honing your skills i can offer you a
deal on your first purchase
absolutely
you only get a deal on the first
purchase okay let's read through these
here sentry
uses energy spawn a spirit orb that
attacks for you
that's cool spirit smash pound foes with
a strong sweeping blow
destroys unstable ground
so that would be useful for traversal if
if i'm right like if it will
eventually we can buy all these but we
only get the deal on the first one i
think it's what he's saying
uh spike throw a powerful spear of light
uses a large amount of energy destroy
that also destroys unstable ground
throw a star that returns to you the
spirit star
blaze jeez set nearby enemies on fire
dude i could see this one right here
will be super useful i feel like
especially later on when you're fighting
bosses and maybe multiple enemies on
screen
but the spirit smash pound foes with a
strong sweeping blow and destroys
unstable ground that's where i'm leaning
right now
although i mean setting nearby enemies
on fire sounds pretty insane too
the reason i'm leaning spirit smash is
because it doesn't use any energy
whereas the
spike does all right let's do it
make the most of your new skill the next
won't come so cheaply all right
so we go into the spirit shrine to use
our skills
keep your blade at the ready and an eye
on the sky
the rumor or new rumor rather
according to over a shrine stands in
inkwater marsh near the entrance to
cuolox hollow
yep i mean we were kind of heading that
way anyway so
it's going to be perfect all right but
how do i do this do i need to set this
yes i do so i'm going to assign it to a
whoa
[Music]
you can do it in midair too
oh man i did not know if that would work
jeez jeez
okay i feel like we could probably
yeah i was about to say i think we can
reach this right here
oh wait but now what there we go
just gotta hop out a little bit
[Music]
dude that launched us up
okay okay
all right i need i need to deal with
this guy
i need to deal with this guy first okay
let's try this thing about gaining uh
energy back
and it used up how much did he use up it
didn't even like show me
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be able
to tell because i didn't know beforehand
how much i had i'm at 181 i did spend
400 to buy that little power up
wait what why didn't i make it that time
okay hold on hold on hold on
what
[Music]
there we go all right so
if i hold up can i grab onto that right
there
[Music]
oh wow he went super high that time
what in the world
let's see if we go to the left there we
go
is this all that's up here surely not
surely not got to be something more than
that
uh oh i don't like the looks of that guy
at all
jeez two bashes of that new move though
and we took him out
all right
like are you serious like i don't
understand why he can't make this thing
swing
i feel like i've got to be pushing the
wrong button or something
maybe not though i mean maybe that's
just not a mechanic they're interested
in having
and i want to get up there but i don't
think we can
oh hey guys we mock i saw where the
little owl fell
near the home we left behind silent
woods
scary woods okay
okay
this doesn't look good oh there he is
no he looks so sad
we're getting it to place him oh man i
thought we were
quote luck is kind pollock will help
yikes what's happening
whoa who was that who's that up there
are you friend or foe oh i feel like i
should be able to
slide through the cracks right there
right
shouldn't we
it's not letting us though oh it's that
dude
talk again what's up the gays of the
great quote admits
only the worthy or so the legend says of
course this
isn't quo lock it's just a statue
come to think of it it doesn't have any
eyes either how's it supposed to gaze at
anything
some legends
when the light left the spirit willow
and decay spread through the land he was
watching
if it weren't for him the mokai might
not have had a place to go
when the woods might not have had a
place to go when the woods
where they used to live grew too
dangerous okay that was
sentences that's why the quo look
and jesus that's why they call quo lock
their guardian he's kept
the decay at bay for now
all right so what am i supposed to do
i saw a little lever right there so
we'll definitely pull yeah so we're
heading in this direction now
so i guess we're gonna have to try and
explore this later because i completely
missed it somehow
oh wait wait wait no no no i want to
check i want to check for this right now
we'll be back talk we'll be back oh i
messed up
dude i don't even know if we can get out
of here hold on
no yeah i don't think we can get back
out so we might be
we might have to full commit to this now
oh man i feel like i remember something
about warping in previous in the last
game
that might be something i have to unlock
though track quest
nope it's not gonna let me it's not
gonna let me
all right so i guess on we go
[Music]
oh wait is that gonna help me get back
no it just lowers the water
all right so we're gonna be going down
yikes
all right we took him out
okay that this is where we were earlier
all right so yeah let's drop down right
here
yes there we go absorb the light
that's what i'm talking about
spirit arc you've gained a new dude
we're gaining so many abilities so
fast and this looks like uh an
arrow of some kind hold zl to assign it
and fire away
okay i don't man i hate that we only
have three spots though
i'm gonna put it on x right now because
regenerate i mean
i mean regenerates handy but
i don't see that being super useful
right now
let's go let's go
energy cell fragment to collect one more
to increase your maximum
energy
wait does that use energy yeah it does
whenever i blast that
but this does not using this does not
use energy
so wait that's energy then it doesn't
take anything i thought it took
away i thought it took away those uh
little gold orbs right there but that i
don't think that's correct
dude so wait can i
jump back up oh but it's going to keep
going back down
dude how do we get up there
oh no i don't think we can go this way
either
that's what i tried to do earlier that
didn't let me
oh i can use this one now
you know what you just stay away
dang it takes a lot of those to take him
out
nice now we got up here though
oh don't do that
i knew it was gonna go back in quickly
no can we really not destroy that
oh wait we can't destroy it but
we can do that an
eye stone this curious eye shaped gem
would fit nicely
into a stone eye socket that might be
how we get to see that
that guardian quo lock or whatever his
name was
i think that might be how oh it labels
our buddy talk right there okay okay
all right so we haven't explored
anything over here i still need to go
back and check out that shrine
all right but first i'm gonna see if
there's any way
to get over to this way
yeah we can climb this
all right that's one of these where we
can do this so yeah we can launch really
high off this
wait where's the thing in this one oh
it's right there
no oh my goodness i just fell
all the way i just fell
all the way down you guys
yeah i'm gonna need to blast that one
again
i can't believe that dude now i gotta
get all the way back over here
all right so it's right here so what is
the strategy here for hitting this
what we're gonna have to do
yeah i think if we swing right here
there we go all right that's two of them
this curious eye shape jim yep nicely
into the stone eye socket
okay so before i go over to the right
though
which i'm pretty sure it wants me to
take those and go this way
i'm gonna drop down here
and i'm gonna try and go to that shrine
so i feel like it'll be worth it like
even though it's not it's clearly not
part of the main
quest here i feel like it'll be
something valuable
dude
man we have quickly added to our arsenal
though in terms of attacks
all right so those give me more of the
energy that's right that's right
okay let's go this way
yeah we definitely need help though
definitely need health
whoa
no are we blocked
is this seriously blocked right now you
have to be kidding me
it doesn't show anything right there
no get up get up darn it
yeah i can't believe that's just
completely blocked off
that doesn't help either i was hoping
that would help
all right maybe there's something over
here that we can use to help us
nah this is not gonna help me get over
there
or unless yeah i think we're gonna have
to go down we're gonna have to go
underneath
is that is that supposed to be breakable
right here
dude i saw it i saw it break
all right is there something in here
first
no okay
yes we're on the right path guys
[Music]
oh this is interesting all right let's
crawl around
i'm scared
oh man you know we need to get up there
okay that was just an enemy i guess
oh i really want to get over there
i'm not sure how to do it
yeah i don't know that we can right now
okay we're here let's just go on over
first
the inkwater shrine rumor investigated
oh yeah you know we gotta check out that
rumor
you know we gotta check out that rumor
why can't i hit that
okay fine
initiate the combat shrine
oh yeah we're gonna take you out oh no
there's another one now
oh we already got him
dude terrible i'm doing terrible
all right that's one you know we're not
done
yikes
i shouldn't have gotten hit by that guy
at all
oh one hit when you hit him with the uh
yeah we're definitely going to do this
again oh
that was new that was new
all right we can't take any hits on
these guys right here
they're really not that hard
their attacks are very telegraphed
all right we still got three health orbs
doing okay
i was like how far out does that thing
go
yikes that was a big hit right there
all right we took him out that's it
that's it we got this shard slot upgrade
you can now equip
more shards at once i knew it dude i
knew it
find more shard slot upgrades to equip
even more shards yeah those shards are
insanely good so wait what you can do it
again what
why would you need to do it again all
right see now we
could if we wanted to go with that
with the reckless increased damage dealt
i mean we might as well
because it's going to give us more
damage overall and then we only take a
five percent
five percent more damage because we're
combining it with the
resilience here now if we could upgrade
resilience
that would be really nice
that would be really nice all right
let's go ahead and keep going this way
if i remember right there's something to
the right
we already took care of the shrine oh
there's one of those ore things over
here at a breakable floor right here
and then looks like another secret right
here yeah there's
there's still a lot of stuff over in
here guys
can we make that yes
thank you for the health we definitely
needed that
oh wow this guy's got a lot of health
okay we can break it from this side now
this area is open
nice very very nice
let's get up here
yeah i don't think we i don't think we
have the ability we need to get through
there right now
i do not think we have the ability
to get through there but we should if
that new ability i purchased
we should have the ability to break this
floor over here
yeah right below me
ouch
no how do we get up there
oh yes
large spirit light container spirit
light can be traded yeah we we know
about that
all right so wait wait did i just go
right by this
what i do not remember seeing a
breakable
floor anywhere
oh it's right here and yes
indeed so that thing i bought does work
right there
and then we got a lifestyle fragment
that's one we need one more to be able
to increase
it all right so we've made some good
progress guys
we have made some good progress we've
already got a lot of upgrades here in
our first time
checking out ori and the will of the
wisp so i think we're gonna wrap it up
there thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon hope
everybody has a fantastic rest of
your week later guys